and that's what you gotta let i mean we
gotta let go as actors we can't it's
none of our business what other people
think about it okay but on the same note
i have a question for you i listened to
one of your episodes lately with the guy
from the flash no this is good okay you
guys are talking about how you can never
you can never allow yourself to really
enjoy your experience and and part of my
heart broke because it's like
a lot of actors go their whole career is
never able to enjoy anything they've
ever done and i don't think anyone's
ever been able to
say
why you can
like it's it's you know i mean like a
lot of people go through their lives
just you know like i'm so miserable and
misery is such a motivation
um
and i don't know how to get through that
but
i guess my point
i did that going through smallville and
now that time has passed i actually am
not able to appreciate it somehow right
and
i don't know you just spoke specifically
about how like you're never happy no i'm
sorry not then you're heavy but like
when you perform you're like
it stresses me out i try i just want to
enjoy myself i i don't think i've ever
really there are moments when i'm really
comfortable on set and i enjoy things
but
overall i put so much pressure on myself
to be great that it's hard to enjoy what
you're doing when you just are always
striving to be great and not just
enjoying the moment i think that goes
with life it's like if you're not in the
moment how are you going to enjoy it
you're always ahead of yourself you're
stressing out about things and how do
you how do you deal with that
well i you know you brought up having
kids my kids have taught me
how to be in the moment because
i mean
when you're on set you're in the moment
because somebody says action or go and
you're you know you're there
and
if you're not there you probably don't
stand a chance at least for that scene
or whatnot but with your kids and maybe
your frustrations building or this and
that but you're like but even my wife
has told me like it's all temporary so
it's gonna change in probably 15 minutes
anyway whatever's going on the happiness
or the or the frustration so just
just enjoy it because your kids are
going to grow and they're going to be
gone before you know it so the going
back to your earlier question about kids
like that's what it's teaching me
appreciate what's happening right now
whether it's good or bad right and i
think that's that's left out a lot about
appreciation like are you only supposed
to appreciate everything good about this
moment no
maybe appreciate what can you learn from
this moment i think is the way to get to
appreciation
somebody just ran into you in their car
this is a horrible example
but mother
yeah
but if somehow you can get to what can i
learn from this moment you you will
actually maybe be able to be in the
moment more i'm gonna help mean navigate
other moments so it's like you know what
take a deep breath
like being here i'm alive this is an
accident how do we do with this you know
there's there's a way of programming
to program your mind to make you sort of
not freak out about everything and that
goes with years of therapy and other
things like that